- So you guys just celebrated
it's your one year anniversary?
- We did.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- That's so cool.
- I didn't think, I did not
ever think I'd get married.
I didn't think I was
gonna be a marriage person
but I'm enjoying it tremendously.
- That's awesome.
I never thought I'd get married.
It didn't work for me.
But I never thought
I'd get married though.
I didn't.
And it can be wonderful.
- What I would love about
about you and this show
is how open you are because
so many people we know we live
in a world where people want
to be glossy and perfect.
- [Kelly] I am unfiltered.
- The fact that you come out
here and you're just like,
yeah, marriage, not it.
- Not for everyone, yeah.
- I think I had to obviously
find someone very
specific who would be down
to do marriage the way
that I want to do marriage.
- Absolutely, yeah, I'm not against it.
I think it's a beautiful thing
and I think it's so wonderful too.
Like even we have a couple
on today later in the show
and they're like older
and they just got married
and they're like 80s
and 90s and I'm just
like that's beautiful.
I think it's beautiful.
But I do think we all
because of how we grew up,
we all our love languages are differently.
You have to find someone that kind
of matches you and you grow together.
I think that's important.
- And think it's beautiful
if you're getting to do it.
If you're doing it in your 80s and 90s
you're doing it on your own terms.
And I think so many
of us were sold a specific
bill of goods about what sort
of a heterosexual partnership
was supposed to look like.
And I think one of the benefits of having
had little experience under my belt
before I got married was I was like
I was up for living a very different kind
of life where I was doing it on my own.
And then he just happened
to make that life better.
- Oh, that's so cool.
You found something that compliments you.
That's amazing.
- And I hope I compliment him.
I keep talking about how he
has to follow all my rules
and how he compliments me.
- We know you're kidding, we know.
- Okay, thank you.
- We know you're being funny.
- Thank you.